me
私はですね2008年から2年間 jica ボランティアという形で
野球の普及数をしてまいりました
でえっとそこにその派遣された国というのが
ブルキナファソという国です
ここの国ですね
派遣されていました
であのブルーキー那覇ぞという国はですねちょっと紹介させていただきますけどあの西
アフリカに位置してまして
あの周辺国で言うとガーナとかコートジボワールだとか
ニジェールマニーという国に囲まれたない上拾石です
もともとがフランスの植民地の時代がありまして
公用語はフランス語をしゃべります
8後産業はですね主な産業は農業国なので皆さん農業に従事されております
ただの世界最貧国の1つと言われていまして
もう本当にほぼほぼ課題だらけです問題だけというか本当に単純に教育も医療も農業も
産業もすべてにおいて a 問題があり今もそれは続いています
そう言うと彼ので野球を普及しましょうという活動でした
当時はですねあの私元々そこに配属された時にスポーツ賞
一応スポーツ賞というものがありましてスポーツ賞の野球連盟に配属になりました
ねえ野球連盟があるくらいなので
まぁちょっとは環境があるんじゃないかなと思いますよね
野球連盟がんですよじゃあ野球をする環境があるんでしょうと思って行ってみたらです
ね
まず野球のグラウンドはなかったですし野球用語もない
野球の指導者もいない野球の選手もいない
野球連盟は資金もないと言う当時は
25デー
本当になどんなそんな人生経験もないのでもう
をどうしようかなでも入ったからには何かしないとということでまずできることから
やろうということで
行ったのはですねえっとりあえず子どもたちがいるところに行きました
まあ良く言ったのが小学校だとか
子どもたちが集まってそうな広場とかに入って野球の体験会をするということをしまし
た
で子どもたちが集まりますうわーっなんだなんだなんだなんだなんかどっから来たの
なんか中国の人間がなんか変なボールもってあのうなんか棒切れみたいでばぁば売っ
てるぞみたいなのがあっあーって集まるんだよで大いっぱい来てくれる
やったと思ってで野球の普及活動をしてました
でもですね野球は継続できませんでした
あの発展していかなかったです
理由は簡単で野球するメリットなんかないんですよ
アフリカの子たちが野球をして何のメリットがありますかね
でお父さんお母さんかにすごい言われる
あの家の息子に何か変なボールで遊ばしてどうすんだって
あの意味あるのか腹が減るだけだ
腹が減るだけだしうちの子はバカになるし何の印もないじゃないかって
こんなことをさせる意味がないそれだったら家の仕事を刺した方がいいし
家の手伝いをさせて少しでも買って家庭が少しでもね豊かになればいいじゃないかって
言われました
皆さんどう思いますか
何も言えないですよ
本当に何も言えなくて
そうですねって言う
いう会員4
んです
本当にすごくあのを自分はすごく志を持って何かつこそこの国に
お役立て出来ることがあればなと思って
行ったんですけど
何もできなくて
自分って何だろうって存在にもないし
衣類もないし
必要品とされないんですよ
であればここにいる意味がないなと思ってその時の jica の職員の方にですね
ここで野球をするのはちょっとまだ早いんじゃないですかまずインフラ整備しないと
いけないしねもっともっとの園生活の基盤となるものを作らなきゃいけないじゃない
ですかって
お伝えしたんですけどその時の jica の職員の方が
まず何かやれって言うじゃん
いやーなんかやったんですやったんですけどいらないって言うんですっ
ねぇ
それは本当に某大変ででアド非常に自分の中ではもう
何もできないネガティブなことしか考えられないのでそこから半年間は一切
自分の活動はも貼ってもしないし継続もできない中もうネガティブな状態しかないです
もう運動でもや日本に変えたいと思っていました
ってですねただ
この話はこれで終わらないんですちゃんと良いストーリーもあります
さてですねあの本当にこれも
この偶然が無ければ今ここにも立ててないと思いますし
この活動も継続できていないですし
私もこういう人間になってないと思ってるんですけどあのある子がですね私に興味を
持って話をかけてくれた子がいます
おファンドアミールくんっていうんですねこの子
ないい顔してますよね当時10歳の子で
私が住んでいた裏に住んでいた子で
なぜかですね彼は僕に興味を持ってその一緒に野球をするようになったんです
んで
それもなぜか彼は毎日来るんです
毎日くんですよ卍きてキャッチボールしてバーンまあまあ焼きやってああ知って言って
帰るんですごく彼はいい球を投げるんです
なんでいい球投げるのか聞いたらいや石遊びしてから石石なげてんだみたいな
ああっ
いいし投げてるからそんなにいい球投げの神楽いいいい球を投げるんですよ
デイ
もう
ほんとねえその毎日野球やって帰ってって帰ってって僕ちょっと疑問に思って
そんな2枚につきててお父さんとかお母さんとかからね
怒られて数症って大丈夫はみるって言って言ったら
アミールはそんな関係ない
楽しいからやる
それだけだから明日も来るといって明日も来ました
それでアミルにや野球って9人でやるスポーツなんですよ
なのでアミールは友達いるかって言ったら
あミイラですね友達はって集めて12人集めました
1012キターと思ってよしよしこれでチーム作ろうっていう風になったんですね
でそのときの地域の名前をとってですねチーム軍ゲンっていう名前のチームを作りまし
た
私はですねようやく活動ができるようになりました
様子ですあのあございます
ています
あの時は本当にあの
やい人間って必要とされないと
苦しいんですよいる意味がないと価値がないととしても前を向けなかったりするんです
ね
ただその時子供かもしれないですよ12兄の子かもしれないけど彼らは僕を必要として
くれたんです
で一緒に野球をやったんです遊びかもしれないです
でもあの子たちは僕と一緒に野球をする量
なって
それから10年の付き合いをしていますけどあの
そこからですねカツ取って大きく飛躍しましてい
で位すごいきっかけは単純です単純なきっかけなんです
でそれは何かというとですね
練習しているときに
アミールかと
隆太僕いう立つですが u ターンあのボールってどうやったら早く投げれるんだ
って聞いてきましたで僕はそのとき知っている知識でああこういうふうにカラダを使っ
たらボールって早く投げれるよとかこういう風なトレーニングをしたらいいんだよって
彼に伝えるです
てそしたら彼は
そこで
それって何でってきくっ
答えられないですね
何でだってそういうもんだからって僕は思っていたんです
でも彼は何でそれはそういう動きをしたらそうなるんだっていう根拠を求めてきたです
でその根拠を僕は伝えることができずに
何でなんだろうって思ってましたでふと思ったのが
自分は当時25で
25年間そういえば自分は
こうやれっていう風に言われたことだけをやって誰だって思って
まあそれが自分の親にしても学校の先生にしても自分に教えていただける人たちの声と
いうのは
根拠を持ったことが聞いたことないなとなんでそれをするんですかって
だってみんなそうだからって言うからそうかと思いながらやるんですよ
でもアミュたちは
彼だってその文化的に論理的に物事を考える習慣もあったので
なんでって聞くんです
ごたえられずみました
そこからちょっと自分の習慣を変えるようにしました
a
まずはですね何かするときに対して仮説を立てて
でそれがどういう風になるかっていう感じを野球するです
でこういう動きをしたらどうなるのかとかこういう風なトレーニングをしたらどうなる
のかっていうのを一個一個
仮説を立ててやるって言うことをやっていくと
なんか自分の根拠が出てきているんですよ少しずつはこれたこうなるからこれやると
こういう風になるんだよって
アミルたちに言っておくと少しずつ自分たちの納得をしてじゃあそれをやる
じゃあそれをやったらこうなるんでしょうって
だからやるよーっていう風になってってでどんどんどんどん腕もまあ
能動的にいろんなことをやるようになってきました
そこから
今ですね自分たちがすごく大切にしているというのが物語をこう
描くということを考えていますで当時はですね
あの何がをするにしてもダメダメな国なわけですよ
できないっていうところがあったのでじゃあもう誰にも教えを購入しても私そのとき
日本人は私だけでしたんでもう独自に考えちゃうと思っていいんですよ考えても誰も何
も言わないわけですから
じゃあもう自分で考えてもう自分でストーリーだって作っちゃえばいいんじゃないかな
と思って
でそれを1個以降根拠を作れば
みんな納得するだろうと思ってそういう仕組みをとっていこうというふうに思いました
でですねそれをやっていくと
omar 面白いことにですね自分たちのこの
僕らは今すごい大事にしてなこの未来を描くずっとでそれを逆算的に考えましょうって
いうストーリーを考えても普通はなんかゴールを決めたらそれをじゃあそのゴールに
向かって頑張っていこう
やるんですよねですの僕らはゴールを決めたらじゃあ
そのゴールを足した理由って何だろうって考えます
このゴールにたした根拠
その根拠が見つかればじゃあ
たっするわけですよねってなるわけですじゃあその次の段階の
その根拠って何ですかこういう結果があったからとかこういう実績ができたからこの
結果になったんですっていう根拠になるんで
じゃあその次も行ってその次も言って去っていって言ってた最終的に今の自分になるん
です
その自分になったときに
僕らはじゃあ今の僕たちとその未来の自分の誤差ってどんだけあるのかなっていうの5
税務出すんです
ズレがあるかどのズレがあってよす凛と0
何を知っていて何を知らなくて何をやっていて何をやっていないのかっていうのを全部
出した
ラーですね
明日やることが出てくるんですよ
そうすると
アミルたちは
を押しじゃあ僕たちもそれをやるよなぜならここにたどり着くんでしょうっていうわけ
ですね
で私たちそういう未来を逆に描くストーリーを作ってやってます
ヒアルものじゃあ
何があったから僕たちはプレー級選手になっかっていう想像するんですよもうここはも
想像の世界なのでもう
嘘も本当も何もないんですよ創造ですでその先にじゃあどんな経験をしてどんな実績が
できたから評価を受けたのかって考えるになりました
でその後にその経験と彼はどんな環境があったらできますかって
でその環境の先にじゃあどんな知識とか方法論があったらそれが
進んでいくでしょうかっていう風に考えてやったんですよ
でそれを進むとですねこれちょっとちょっと映像がありますけど
いやーんん
エンジンあーっあーっいいやってやってっ
その1年の中で僕たちのそのフランをつくっているてグランドを作った
yahoo 環境をつくって野球の知識を覚えてっていうのを一つ一つやっ売ってっ
行くとあら不思議ですよ
で思うはぁ
ああああああ
8この後皆さんどうなったかねこれ
えっと9年前の話ですはい
9年前ですでその後なぁになったかといったら
プロ野球選手が誕生する
[拍手]
8左側がですねえっと高知ファイティングドッグスというところで今所属しているさん
フォらしいなぁっていう子です
で右側が新潟アルビレックスのざぶ0時によっていう選手なんですけどこの二人はその
軍件から出てまして
残念ながらまだアミールは出てないんです
ただあのアミールはすごい重要な一部まいりまして彼は本当にオーガナイズする力が
すごいあるので
日本語もすごい上手に喋るようになってますし彼は彼で重要な
役割をしてますけどこういう
状況作るようなことができました
ええ
でですね
今私ちょっと今現在の話をしますけど a 棟
もう少しで東京オリンピックがありますで東京オリンピックに向けて
あのなんとですね今年の6月に私はブルキナファソの代表監督に就任することになり
ます
[拍手]
あの人生ってほんとわかんないものである
これボク前で描けてなかったです10年前にあの子たちの夢は描けてゴールに達するだ
と思ったんですけど
これは
自分が好意なるとは思ってなかったというかここにいることも持ってなかったですし
a
ほんと人生と面白いなぁと言う
空気と思いますはい
でその後の a も描いてまして今僕たちが描いている
まあこれが最後になるか最後にならないかわかんないですけど描いているのがあの
ブルキナファソでボールパークを作りたいね
えーこれはですね西アフリカの諸国を巻き込んでですね
baseball league をつくりましょうとアフリカ初のベースボール
リーグを作ります
性っていうのが今僕たちのまあ
大きい有名なんですけどでそれをどうやったら成し遂げられるかって考えた時に
まあ野球のグランド作っただけじゃ野球はできるけどそれはリーグにはならないから
街作んなきゃダメだっていう話になって街つくるって言ってもね
あのブルキナファソの人たちはまだまだそのいろんな部分で課題があるから
よし人材育成をしようということで
オリンピックが終わった後に日本語学校をつくって
でそこで人いろんな職種の方を招いて人材を育成してで日本の企業さんとタイアップし
て日本で系樹脂を受けた後に
ブルキナファソに還元してやろうっていうでそこからこういろんな人たちを巻き込んで
ペースボールリーグを作れたらねというのが
ありますなんかもう何かぶっ飛んでるかもしれないんですけど見えてるんですよ
入れてるんです
いけません映像最後になります8この10年間で自分がのすごくブルキナファソで学ば
せていただいたことっていうのは
まぁ当時何もできないというところからだったんですけどあの
今思えば
何もないブルキナファソだったからこそ自分はこうしていられるんだろうなって思って
います
あの
できないできないでもそれをちょっと公視点を変えてしまえばじゃあ
グランドがないじゃあグランド作ったらいいじゃないですか
野球用具がねえんだってそれも作ったらいいし指導者がいねぇな育てればいいですよ
じゃあその一歩を踏み出すためにはじゃあ何をするのかといったらやっぱり希望を作る
ないと人間って前でなくてあの
アフリカの人たちにしてもきっと日本の人たちにしてもそうなんですけど何か希望が
あるからじゃあした僕頑張ってみようかってなる
ですねそれがあるからこそ
みんな豊かにこう前向きになって人生をこう楽しめるのであの脳のというふうに皆さん
色々とこう
日本いると思うことはあるかもしれないんですけど日本はもういろんな事がもう
凝り固まってしまってるんで
あのたまにちょっとこう緩やかな視点を持っていただいてあの
前を向いたときにこれってイースに変わるなって思うときがあったらあとはもう映画君
です
ゴールを描いてじゃあそれをどうやったら実現できるのかというのをコンコンコンコン
コアンて考えたらあじゃあ明日
一歩やってみようかなってなったらもう
もう人生楽しいと思います
生きてるってとても素晴らしいことですしあの
いろんなことを巻き込んでいろんな人たちと一緒になってこう
楽しい人生を送っていけたらなあというふうに
思っています本日はありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]